hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain the american drama thriller
film called stonehurst asylum
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie an oxford
university professor demonstrates a case
of female hysteria on eliza graves
before his class she protests that she
is sane but the professor mercilessly
triggers her hysteria by touching her
inappropriately
any human touch sends her into a
frenzied state after the demonstration
he asks his assistant to bring in the
next patient
cut to christmas eve a young doctor
edward newgate from oxford arrives at
the stonehurst asylum
he is led by guards and the head of the
guards mickey finn
into the building the asylum consists of
200 residents
most of them are lords and ladies of the
finest families of britain
dr edward is there to gain clinical
experience for his further medical
practice
he meets the superintendent of the
asylum dr silas lamb
edward impresses dr lam with his will to
work with the mentally challenged
so dr lam invites edward to the
afternoon rounds with him
he introduces him to the patients of the
stonehearst
some think they are animals some
delusional while some of them are there
for being homosexual
but one patient in particular catches dr
edwards eyes
lady eliza graves the woman shown at the
beginning of the film
she is in the asylum getting treated for
female hysteria
she belongs to a noble family and is
married to a very wealthy man
unfortunately lady eliza suffers from
hysteria
she reacts negatively to all physical
touches she bit her abusive husband's
ear off
so she was sent to the asylum by her
father dr
edward is fascinated by eliza's musical
skills
he seemed to have charmed her as well
edward is surprised by dr lam's unique
way of treating his patients
rather than working on fixing their
problems he celebrated their conditions
and allowed them to live happily in
their delusions
dr lam invites edward for a staff dinner
that night
many dishes lay etiquettely on the
dining table but edward is surprised to
see patients joining them on the table
according to dr lam it is therapeutic
for the patients to mix with the polite
society
at the dinner everyone is having
cheerful conversations until dr
edward mentions that mickey finn is a
funny name this causes tension in the
dinner
everyone goes silent but mickey finn
starts to laugh hysterically
he then offers dr edward a glass of
alcohol
he is about to drink it when lady eliza
from below the table
hits him with her legs doctor drops the
liquor
then eliza brings him out with an excuse
of cleaning his shirt
and tells him to run away from the
asylum as soon as he can
she gives no reason as to why that night
edward goes to his room confused
he prepares his gun in case he needs it
in the future a loud noise startles
edward
he follows it and reaches down to the
basement there are several people in
prisons begging for his help
his first thought is that they are
extremely insane patients but after a
chat with them
he realizes that they are the actual
staff and superintendent of the asylum
lam was actually a patient who led a
mutiny he locked up the staff
and let the patients run things
including finn among the prisoners are
the actual superintendent of the asylum
dr benjamin salt two nurses a health
guide and many others
they were given a drink with some drugs
and brought down to the basement
edward realizes that he would have ended
up like them if lady eliza hadn't saved
him today
horrified edward rushes to tell eliza
the truth
but she already knows all of it in fact
she is one of the lunatics who helped dr
lam imprison the staff
the next day lam takes edward and mickey
finn with him on his afternoon rounds
they make edward go into a lunatic's
room to change his dressing
the lunatic is terrifying to look at
when edward initially approaches him
he is attacked by the man he is almost
about to choke edward to death
but soon he notices the name arthur
written on the wall
edward assumes that it is the lunatic's
name so he calls him arthur
this finally calms the man down dr
lam is impressed but edward ends up with
many injuries after the encounter
lady eliza looks after his wounds edward
tells her about his intentions of
freeing the prisoners and running away
with them at that time she reveals that
back then
stonehurst asylum was a cruel place for
the patients where they were
experimented upon by dr salt
his ways and ideas matched that of the
devil's lamb
mickey finn eliza the cooks and the
guards were all the victims of dr salt's
cruel method
he touched eliza inappropriately to
trigger her hysteria with an excuse of
finding her a cure
he applied severe water pressure on some
of his patients and kept them in the
running water for days
according to dr salt a patient's worst
fear is the way to cure their madness
but he struggled to find lamb's worst
fear dr salt performed all kinds of
terrifying procedures on lamb when he
was a patient
lamb and other patients had come to
despise dr salt so they planned for
months
the way to free themselves of the
torture finally
one day they spiked the doctor and
staff's drink and imprisoned them
lamb took dr salt's place as the chief
of the asylum and let the patients live
freely
he employed some of them as the
gatekeepers some as cooks and some as
nurses
he gave all their life a purpose and
made stonehearst a happy place
after hearing the story edwards promises
that she will never again have to suffer
the way that she has
shortly edward impresses everyone in the
asylum
an old lady had refused to eat until her
son comes from war
edward poses as her son and lovingly
feeds the lady
seeing this encounter eliza is more
drawn towards edward
his kindness has impressed her the pair
starts to fall in love with each other
edward tries to persuade her to run away
with him from the asylum but eliza is
doubtful of the idea
not long after edward is called by dr
lam
dr lam wants edward to assist him in an
experimental procedure on dr
salt he ties him to the bed dr lam
claims that dr salt is a lunatic who
believes himself to be the rightful
superintendent of stonehurst
and he needs a therapy this therapy is
called electrotherapy
then in front of edward dr lam hits the
switch
electrocuting him he asks edward to do
the same
after the electro therapy dr salt loses
all of his memory
the next day is the new year 1900
everyone in stonehurst is celebrating
unhappy
edward intends to set the prisoners free
tonight a ceremony takes place
everyone is dancing as dr lam watches
them
elsewhere edward knows dr lam has some
good inside him
so he sets out to find it in lamb's room
when he was a patient
edward finds a hidden picture inside the
wall and takes it with him
everyone goes outside the building to
celebrate the coming of the new century
but edward stays inside to spike the
champagne with a chemical that will make
everyone unconscious
however mickey finn catches him in the
act after an intense fight edward frees
himself from finn
the spiked champagne is brought to the
celebration and distributed to everyone
but as they are about to drink it mickey
finn stops them and edward's act is
caught
dr lam hits him with a bottle when
edward opens his eyes
he is tied to a hospital bed and is
being taken into the electro therapy
room
dr edward is about to be electrocuted as
dr salt did
just then eliza comes into the room with
edward's pocket watch
it has a picture of eliza on it she
assumes that her husband had sent
edward to get her out of the asylum she
asks him for his real intentions for
coming into the asylum
he reveals that six months ago he was in
a medical lecture
where a doctor displayed eliza and her
medical disability
he felt so pitiful and saddened by her
condition he vowed to save her from that
hell
this was the real reason edward had come
to the stonehurst asylum
as he is being taken away he asks eliza
to run away from the asylum
just as dr lam is about to electrocute
him edward requests a final will
his request is to give eliza graves the
picture that is in his pocket
but in reality the picture is the one
edward had found in lamb's room
dr lam takes a look at it and he is
shocked the picture is the root cause of
his madness
it is revealed that dr lam was a real
doctor in the war
he had to kill his soldier friends to
free them of the pain
he had shot each of them to death and
had tried to kill himself too
but he ran out of bullets this turned
him in saying with time
the picture edward showed him was the
picture of one of lam's soldier friends
so it triggered his madness again dr lam
runs away from there
seeing this mickey finn decides to
perform the procedure on edward himself
but eliza comes to edward's aid the
whole asylum watches them fight
cheerfully
however finn triggers her hysteria by
touching her trigger point
sending her into a frenzied state edward
manages to calm her down
then the fight continues mickey finn
finally gets electrocuted and burns to
death
but the fire spreads around and the room
starts burning
eliza runs to save the prisoners from
the basement while edward goes looking
for lamb
he finds him in the hallway out of his
mind and deluded
so edward brings him outside with other
patients
all of them are safe now everything is
over
edward wants eliza to come to a new
place with him but eliza refuses
they kiss their last goodbye when edward
tells eliza that he has a final secret
to share
it is now a few months later stonehurst
has become back to normal and is better
than ever
the true head nurse appears to be
running things sometime later
caring for the patients now including
salt and lamb
the oxford professor from the beginning
of the movie and eliza graves husband
arrive at the asylum to release her
but they are surprised to be informed
that dr edward had already discharged
her three weeks ago
the men are surprised to hear this
because the professor himself is dr
edward newgate
the real dr edward he explains that the
person who came here posing as a doctor
was actually a patient of his
he had seen eliza graves in a medical
demonstration at oxford
then he ran away from an asylum in
london with dr edward's belongings and
stole his
identity all in order to save eliza
graves
at the end of the movie we see mrs
graves in the imposter newgate in
tuscany
italy they are now known as dr and mrs
lam
the two dance happily and embrace in the
garden of what appears to be another
asylum
run peacefully by nuns that's the ending
of the movie stonehurst asylum
now for the explanation edward has been
a mentally ill patient all along
he suffers from a condition called
pseudologia fantastica
more commonly known as pathological
lying it is a condition where a person
constantly lies for no personal gain
edward had been doing this for years we
never come to know his real name
but despite of his disorder he possesses
the unique qualities of love and empathy
his love and empathy for mentally ill
people like him made him able to help
those people
even eliza's fear of touch is cured
because of him
because of this edward is able to act
like a sane and normal person
the audience will not think that he is a
madman edward's character is built very
strongly
one of the messages conveyed from this
film is about how great the power of
love is
it is even capable of conquering the
greatest human suffering
an insane soul subscribe for more videos
like this
turn on the notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out
thank you for watching